there is some very strong guy
rated over 3k who wants to play with an
increment that is brilliant okay
let's play him
1a4 okay let's go c5 this time
um let's say 96
takes okay let's go browser
just for fun f3
yeah this system on theory i believe
yeah i think the last time i looked at
it was when i was like
16 or something
and back the time i think we decided a5
bishop b5 bishop e6 is fine
and i guess white had many moves here
like rook d1 was an option castling long
was an option castling short was an
option as well
yeah he goes for this one then i think
knight is seven was a move
yeah take stakes and now maybe a4 yeah
so this is a modern theory i believe
and they say white is sort of better
here
which is probably correct
okay so he doesn't wonder bishop g5
which is unpleasant but we have to live
with it
bringing the knight to c7 was a kid i
believe so normally it's a
it's a very decent regrouping for black
he goes f4 which looks a bit strange to
me
okay let's just take he takes back
yeah maybe it's not that strange
our knight on c7 is um
yeah i sort of liking the squares
yeah it looks unpleasant
maybe we should just
just go for some ending or we can play
queen beat okay let's go queen b8
it looks a little bit strange
[Music]
but i hope it's a long way to get
checkmated and
at the king's side and we'll just try to
we'll just try to finish the development
slowly
um what i want to play here is bishop f6
does it work after queen takes d6
rook d8
feels like it doesn't but okay who
really cares
so after queen takes d6 at very least i
believe we can go knight d5
queen b8 9 takes 3 check bc rook takes
b8
we're still slightly worse
but it's not dramatically bad i believe
or maybe it actually is
yeah another option after quintex d6 is
obviously rook d8
then he has queen c5 and queen b6 so
queen c5 runs into b6
and i think we win a piece and queen b6
the plan was to go knight eight
feels like he has some tactics there
that i don't yet see
okay let's um let's give him a chance to
show it
so once again queen b6 knight a8 queen
c5 b6
what's wrong with it i don't know
maybe nothing but then it's uh it's a
very nice surprise i have to say
because right here it doesn't look good
for black
i mean intuitively 98
i'm probably wondering something but i
don't see that something so
so queen c5 is pretty much forced b6
yeah it's funny but i don't see how
how to keep this going for white
he simply resigned wow that was nervous